Mission Impossible 3 if you guys didn't
know I'm currently in the middle of
reviewing every single Mission
Impossible movie before rogue nation
comes out I've already covered 1 & 2 on
my channel those reviews are up right
now if you want to check them out let's
start talking about the one that finally
picked things back up again after two
was like no in Mission Impossible three
Tom Cruise as Ethan Hunt is about to get
married to Michelle Monaghan this girl
is like everything for him she's showing
him what life beyond IMF is like and
Ving Rhames as luther stickell is back
and thank goodness because he's one of
the best parts of all these movies and
he's like no man we can't add that kind
of stuff in our line of work my brother
I don't know about that my friend and
Philip Seymour Hoffman the best villain
in the entire series so far haven't seen
5 yet plays the bad guy in this movie
and hunt is on a mission to try to
capture this man and he seems to be
slipping through their fingers all the
time just like my first two Mission
Impossible reviews there are going to be
some minor spoilers impossible major
spoilers throughout this review so if
you haven't seen mi3 yet go check it out
and then come back and watch my review
you have been warned
let's talk in depth about this movie
first off Aaron Paul's in this one yeah
watching it again I was like holy crap
that's Aaron Paul right there and there
are good things and bad things to mi3 I
don't think it's a flawless movie at all
there are definite things that have
improved over Mission Impossible 2
though for one the biggest thing is that
they understand that Ethan Hunt is not
James Bond this guy is not a playboy
swinger who goes around sleeping with
women smiles and winks at cute girls and
then does impossible things
without ever getting hurt because that's
what mi-2 was trying to be it was trying
to be the later Pierce Brosnan era James
Bond movies and it didn't work out and
my three recognizes that these are
people and JJ Abrams took over as
director for this movie this was his
first feature film that he directed and
he does a really good job for the most
part helming the action scenes and even
the dramatic scenes he understands what
this series needed at the time and it
was some serious adrenaline because mi-2
for the most part was a humongous bore
and although it made a lot of money
really the only reason it made so much
money was because people liked the first
one and what abrams did so well with
this movie was inject that energy into
it this is an extremely fast paced movie
I mean there's rarely ever a dull moment
there's hardly
any downtime in mi3 and I also think
that's mi three's biggest flaw each
scene feels like these gigantic scenes
back-to-back and sometimes these scenes
don't feel like they connect very well
sometimes it's hard to really get inside
the characters heads because they are
always running as fast as they possibly
can or getting adrenaline injected into
their hearts or getting some sort of
thing injected after their nose or
jumping off a roof or flying through the
air or just something crazy that it's
hard to really sit down for a second go
these are characters and that is my
biggest issue with MI 3 there just
wasn't enough character building moments
in between these huge action sequences
that are awesome there are multiple
scenes in this movie that give me the
goosebumps that they're just really
well-done the bridge scene involving
this drone that's just laying waste to
this convoy of vehicles and hunt having
to get inside this car to get this huge
gun to try to shoot at it I mean that is
a fantastic scene it has the big money
shot explosion you all saw a billion
times in the trailers back in the day
one of the earlier scenes in the movie
in which hunt has to rescue a former
teammate of his by infiltrating this
base all really riveting stuff and one
of my favorite parts of mi3 is this
incredible sequence where hunt has to
run about 1 mile to get to this phone
signal and Simon Pegg as Benji and his
first role in the series is leading him
to this signal and you get this epic
like 20 second long unbroken take of
crews just barreling down this road it
is awesome I mean I know a lot of people
make fun of Tom Cruise he likes to run
in his movies but let's face it man he's
pretty frickin good at it and it has
that great stunt sequence where he hops
from rooftop to rooftop there's also a
really dangerous stunt in this movie
that's always impressed me that happens
so quick no one ever talks about it Cruz
is running along the streets of Shanghai
trying to catch this rabbit's foot
device that they are trying to get it's
rolling down the street he finally gets
it and he goes like this and a car stops
right by his head and that thing is
centimeters away from knocking Cruz in
the face that is one of the best stunts
I've seen him ever do it's so quick in
this movie but it looks fantastic one of
the things that Abrams did so well in
this movie is he understood that putting
people human bodies in the same frame
some amazing explosion or action
sequence really lends to the realism and
makes it a lot more intense but at the
same time the cinematography can be a
little crowded in this movie where he
uses close-ups too much in fact Abrams
himself in a documentary said he tends
to use close-ups too much and I can
definitely see that in mi3 in recent
years he's definitely pulled back on
that and that could be from his
background in TV because this is his
first feature film and in television
directors generally use a lot more
close-ups because it's the small screen
because you don't have as big of a
canvas as someone who's directing for a
movie theater would another good
addition to this movie that not too many
people ever really talked about was
Laurence Fishburne as Ethan hunts boss I
thought he was great he was a badass he
has this amazing line where he's like I
kid you not I will bleed on the flag to
make sure the stripes stay red let's
talk a little bit more about Philip
Seymour Hoffman this guy is really good
in this movie the only issue really I
have for this character is that there
just isn't enough emotion given to him
there isn't much of a backstory you
don't really know anything about him
he's just a really evil guy
he's excellent with what he's given
there's an amazing scene on a plane you
have a wife girlfriend wherever she is I
want to find her I'm gonna hurt her yeah
what I did back there with your friend
that was fun that's fun all joking aside
one of the biggest issues with the mi
films that the villains really aren't
that strong Kaufman killed it in this
movie and he brought a good villain to
the franchise finally
so overall mi3 is a really entertaining
movie it was far better than its
predecessor it understood the things
that were wrong with its predecessor
there was more action Ethan Hunt was
actually ethan hunting and he just
wasn't some James Bond superhero guy on
a motorcycle who can fly through the
hair and smack into the villain and not
die instantaneously and although the
plot was going for more humanity it
couldn't really reach that because of
the limitations from the screenplay and
the fact that there are so many
larger-than-life action scenes they all
sort of blend together sometimes and the
structure of the film becomes a little
bit messy everyone's really great in
this film the action and the acting are
all on top of their game it's just that
the film could have used better
structuring still I'm going to give
Mission Impossible 3 of be
so guys I'm looking forward to bringing
you my review from Mission Impossible
Ghost Protocol that's going to be coming
very soon and then at the end of the
month
rogue nation comes out I'm super pumped
to bring that for you guys and as always
thank you so much for watching this and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes